[Music]
which scene was my
favorite to shoot
i i think uh the scene where 3po tells
han solo who's hanging over a fire lit
by ewoks
that han solo is to be the main course
given in a banquet in my honor because
he'd always been mean to three pios i
was kind of bullying him and so on and
being god of the ewoks was great fun but
being in the rise of skywalker was total
joy a lot of work but total joy
throughout because i was with daisy and
oscar uh and um john boyega and we just
had adventures huge fun
[Music]
that would be really mean to pick one
out because you know each actor brings
so many qualities of their own sir alec
guinness of course was
like royalty in a way theatrical royalty
the most wonderful man and then mark
hamill the most honest sort of
easy-going
actor
who made you think that 3po was real and
so that was great but then if we come on
up and we
daisy ridley who i first met when she
was reading the script and she said i'm
playing ray and i had no i hadn't read
the script
but by the time i finished
i knew
how her life was going to change and it
has but she's still the she's just the
same
[Music]
when i came to
running up to this movie i emailed jj
abrams and said
you know 3po works best in these
situations here and here not there not
there not down there
with friends with
something to do
and i'm sure he didn't need me to
nudge him in that way but i think when
you see the rise of skywalker
you will understand that i had a very
good time
um which of course means that 3po
probably didn't have a good time
i'm not saying goodbye to c-3po because
there's all sorts of other uh projects
that are not movies you know for years
i've been doing animated series and
games and so on so
it it's only i think as far as the
movies go and because the rise of
skywalker is such a good ending
to the whole series of episodes it i
think it's better it does end properly
rather than
drift away and become
thin and
meaningless so i feel really good about
it strangely
maybe in a while i will
i will miss it but right now
i also
look forward to getting a better
perspective of the whole
series of films because i've been so
close to them that i i
fans understand them more than i do
isn't that crazy
[Laughter]
working with gary was always
a crazy moment
i just love the opportunises when she
would be talking to threepio and i'm
thinking particularly in uh
in uh episode seven um
the force awakens she
she would just look so honestly
into threepio's eyes and mine she had
beautiful eyes
[Music]
what has 3po taught me over the last
nine films
i don't know i think he's taught me the
value of friendship of loyalty and of
tenacity and endurance that sometimes
you've just got to push forward just
you've said yes you've got to do it so
keep going
[Music]
well now that's an interesting thing i
think
would it be disloyal to 3po to play
somebody else no
i'm open to offers
let the game begin
so i've got nine stills okay
is there a prize uh yes there is cool go
for it
there's an easy one we'll start which
movie
episode two
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
episode five
that would be
uh empire strikes back yes
i thought it's um
it's uh the last jedi yes
i got it i got it
so the phantom menace
i'm on a roll here
[Music]
um oh
i know which one it is um yes it's
episode
seven
force awakens
scary scary eyes jet lag look at that um
that of course is episode nine the rise
of skywalker
ah king of the ewoks don't you love it i
mean god for a day or what it was
fantastic i was a little nervous sitting
in that seat because it was on wires and
i was wondering they'd drop me that of
course is a return of the jedi
and this is a rather sad scene in uh
revenge of their sith
because um
anakin had gone a bit crazy at this
point and i think the jedi temple is
burning in the distance and and dear
padme was so sad and so was 3po
this is my personal favorite scene
that's
that is in
episode four a new hope and that is
funny because i my hands didn't work
they were just clumsy bits of metal and
whatever so to pick up that calm link
meant that i had to
and i only had in that shot the one
where you see me pick it up i only had
that
arm on just jeans and a shirt and i had
to pick it up i had sticky tape in the
middle of my hand so i could slap it and
then hold it like that
cute yes
okay great because yeah so the price
because what i have for you is a
bluetooth enabled
[Music]
you're kidding yes it's an actual
working
bluetooth imperial coming is that real
listen to them they're dying aren't you
i do out my metal body i wasn't fast
enough
that was my least favorite line ever
because my mother
that's so cute um typical of threepio
that he's completely unaware of anybody
else's problems but his own you know
that is people are going to love this
yeah thank you